onset Virginia governor Glenn young
Governor this is your old line of work
um how important is that rating system
and what could that portend of things to
come well I think that what it says is
that the financial profile of the United
States of America is under huge pressure
and and we know that and the American
people know that just ask them just ask
them I mean every Virginian when they go
to the grocery store it's a gut punch
it's a gut punch and what they've seen
since since the recession I mean since
the beginning of the pandem pandemic is
a 40 increase in the cost of groceries
every time they go to the gas pump
that's a shock Witnesses working
Governor we hear speech after speech
media figure after media figure why
aren't American people feeling this yet
Vietnam are the jobs created all the
stuff all this good stuff happening yeah
you can change the words but you can't
change the way people feel when they go
in the grocery store and that's what
Virginians see every day that's what
Americans see every day and this is the
issue which is when you have credit
ratings that are that are dropped when
you have 22-year high in interest rates
when you have inflation that's been run
away even his own Economist told him
this before he let loose just
unparalleled spending it's it's hurting
all Americans and I will tell you I see
it all the time you see folks who just
can't make it work anymore so almost 60
almost 60 of Americans live paycheck to
paycheck because they can't keep up with
the cost of living in America and I see
it in Virginia every day uh yeah I see
it too and Governor I know you're
leading the charge for something we've
been talking about on the angle now for
two and a half years which is early
voting make it easier for people to vote
absentee or are early in person ahead of
the state's crucial off-year election
which is coming up in November so
Republicans can can have like great
policies and great answers to this
economic disaster we're in but if we
don't invest in getting ballots in
people's hands and then returned like
you know Mark Zuckerberg and all these
other people knew was important then
what what is it all for yeah well we're
doing something we have we have a huge
election in Virginia this year it's
Virginia's midterms Our House and Senate
are all up I gotta hold our house we got
to flip the Senate and I need
Republicans to get in the game fully and
so we launched secure your vote
virginia.com to make it easy to schedule
to vote early sign up for our permanent
absentee ballot list order a mail-in
ballot or just make a plan to vote early
but we need everybody to vote I am so
frustrated in watching election returns
on Election Day when when the Democrats
show up with thousands of votes through
absentee ballots and so I said I
inherited these rules when I came in as
Governor we get to choose are we going
to compete are we going to show up down
a thousand votes for a race I'm going to
compete and so we're signing up
Virginians to vote Republicans please
participate Republicans doing you're
doing it in Virginia and we've been
urging you know all these groups that
collect all this money and all these
think tanks out there but what are
Grassroots organized stations doing do
you know well they've gotten started but
I think we're writing a Playbook here in
Virginia what we did was we're
leveraging what Brian Kemp did in
Georgia they did a great job we are now
doing it in Virginia we're going to
write the second edition to this early
voting play book and then hopefully
it'll it'll be the playbook for next
year in 2024. Trump indictment what are
yours what's your sense well I I've said
before that this this two-tiered justice
system on display is eroding everyone's
trust in our legal system and the
reality is if if you're in the
opposition party you're treated one way
and if you're a friend of of the party
in power uh then you're treated a
completely different way and and this is
eroding everyone's faith I hear it every
day in Virginia we can't trust our
justice system do you ever consider
jumping and I can't tell you how many
people ask me because they know I know
you and so forth would would Glenn young
can ever consider if there was an
opening for you to jump in well I'm so
humbled when people say this to me
it's it's well and let me just be honest
I'm so focused on Virginia this year and
we just talked about we have huge
elections and we have a chance in 24
months to take a state that was
completely blue Statewide led the
legislature and in 24 months turn it
Republican and I think we must get this
done we gotta hold our house flip our
Senate and we can move forward with
policies that you know Laura came in
Virginia was bottom third in job growth
we're top five now we in fact have
backed the blue and crimes coming down
we've stood up for parents we've made
we've made government run more efficient
speech Governor well I think that I
think that people are noticing what
we're doing in Virginia and I think
that's why we get so much attention
you're not ruling it out well I am
focused on our elections and we're gonna
we're gonna hold our house and we're
gonna flip our Senate and we're going to
show folks that in 24 short months you
can take a blue state that was lost and
turn it red results Governor young thank
you so much for stopping by in our new
testament I love your new time slot I
look forward to being with you
frequently awesome great to see you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else